[Musik]
meine lieben heute gibt es einen brot
aus der pfanne das ist in der türkei
total beliebt mit sicherheit auch in
anderen ländern
wir machen nämlich basler brot und das
ist erst mal nur hefeteig denn eine
halbe stunde geht und dann wird er nur
in der pfanne ausgebacken und alles
rucki zucki also das ist ein relativ
schnelles brot rezepte und es ist mika
fluffig ich liebe das spiel jetzt auch
direkt an ohne groß drum herum zu
quatschen ich habe hier eine große
schüssel und gibt selbst mal mehr rein
ich mache das gerne so ich nehme mir
jetzt einfach ein kilo gibt aber nicht
alles rein sondern ungefähr 800 gramm
und da kommt gleich eine mode dazu soll
das reicht da gibt es jetzt also da mach
ich jetzt eine molkerei mit dem sauberen
händen gibt da schon mal einen teil des
lauwarmen wasser dazu die ganz klar
mengenangaben findet ihr in der infobox
da gebe ich jetzt die hälfte ein
anschließend einen würfel frischhefe und
etwas zucker
[Musik]
und jetzt einmal fünf minuten zugedeckt
stehen lassen damit die hefe arbeiten
kann so nach fünf minuten konnte die
hefe richtig schön arbeiten und wirkung
zeigen
und da gebe ich jetzt alle anderen
zutaten mit dazu also das restliche
wasser einfach mit in die schüssel und
ich kriege das heute alles mit den
händen ihr könnt natürlich auch den
maschinen eben das vielleicht ein
bisschen einfacher
ich habe salz mit rein also jetzt erst
nicht vorher das ist wichtig dann habe
ich hier lauwarme milch und 1 1
so und jetzt heißt es kneten
[Musik]
und dann eben nach und nach erst mehr
angeben dann habt ihr dieses perfekte
gefühl dafür wann der teig genug mehl
hat und wann so die grenze erreicht weil
er muss noch richtig schön geschmeidig
sein und in der schüssel habe ich jetzt
nicht mehr ausreichend platz
deswegen gibt es einmal auf die saubere
arbeitsfläche und knete das nochmal so
ungefähr 34 minuten lang richtig schön
durch
[Musik]
für den teig gebe ich jetzt zurück in
die schüssel vorher schön mit mehl
bestäuben auch obendrauf ein bisschen
medien denn nicht austrocknet und
natürlich ein sauberes küchentuch drüber
gehen und jetzt muss unsere teig kugel
30 minuten lang ruhen also es ist ganz
wichtig dass jetzt mal kein ort wo es
durch zug gibt das gibt es hier bei uns
war alles offen ist immer deswegen
stellt das gleich einfach in den
backofen der aus ist ansonsten kann ich
euch auch den tipp geben wirklich nur
nach und nach mehr dazu geben ich habe
ungefähr 820 gramm jetzt gebraucht das
kommt natürlich extra geguckt ich habe
auch so mittelgroßes eingenommen es
kommt halt auch immer auf das volumen an
also bis gleich schießen
[Musik]
den aufgegangenen tag habe ich jetzt auf
der bemehlten arbeitsfläche einmal
ausgebreitet und im moment 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 15 8 gleichmäßig große teile geteilt
gelassen das soll nicht irritieren und
es war habe ich die müssen kleiner
gemacht habe ich mir dachte ich möchte
lieber größere boote haben wie kann man
sich dann anschließend immer noch
unterteilt
ihr könnt die größte so wie ihr möchtet
ihr könnt auch 16 kleine brote machen
und wenn man jetzt folgendes die hände
auch am besten immer schön bemühen man
jetzt folgendes einmal jede einzelne
teil kugel formen so dass sie schön rund
ist und dann bereiten wir das aus
entweder nimmt ihr euch nudelholz oder
indem einfach die finger und drückt das
schön runter liegt das auf die mieter
arbeitsfläche und dann lassen wir das
nochmal 15 bis 20 minuten gehen
[Musik]
jetzt durften die bei mir noch mal 20
minuten ruhen 15 minuten gehen auch in
ordnung dass den einfach nur dazu dass
sich der teig noch mal entspannt und
mich noch mal zurück zieht ihr kennt das
wenn ein hefeteig direkt verarbeitet er
zieht sich zurück wenn er unentspannt
ist so und jetzt nehme ich mir hier
schon mal den teig gut dass wir das in
butter ausgelegt haben so kann man das
leichter anheben und dann genau einen
habe ich schon fertig gemacht sondern
jetzt einmal in die heiße pfanne geben
also was ist heiß ich hab jetzt hier
ich hatte anfangs stufe acht von neun
auf sechs runter wenn darauf 5 unter da
müsste einfach so das gefühl dafür
kriegen nicht zu heiß weil es soll ja
richtig innen auch gar werden und außen
nicht zu dunkel
ihr kriegt also auf jeden fall ein
gefühl dafür nach dem ersten
[Musik]
jedes brot wird dann ungefähr
zweieinhalb bis drei minuten von jeder
seite ausgebacken ganz wichtig ohne fett
also wirklich nur in der beschichteten
pfanne und verlasst euch jetzt auch
nicht auf exakt diese angabe weil jeder
herd heizt an dass er vielleicht eine
andere hitze ihr müsst einfach zum
gefühl dafür entwickelt jeder fall ist
anders genau das habe ich beide seiten
direkt nach dem auspacken mit butter
bestrichen
das braucht ja auch das ist ganz wichtig
und jetzt habe ich noch einen top tipp
für euch versucht doch mal butter ag das
ist reines butterschmalz und das ist so
lecker ich gebe auf jeden fall noch mal
auf ein paar wasser massiert dieses
butter geht drauf einfach so und dann
nehme ich jetzt einen pin sind verteilt
das auch von beiden seiten
es hat nicht so einen ganz anderen
geschmack müsste einfach mal probieren
das ist auch mega lecker und total soft
also wenn ihr jetzt auch lust habe auf
dieses mega software basar brot dann
unbedingt hier unten in die video
beschreibung schauen da schreibe ich
euch ganz genau die mengenangaben hin
ansonsten main kanal unbedingt ein
kostenloses abo da lassen und wenn ihr
möchtet mache ich mehr brot rezepte auch
mehr in die orientale sprecherin die
indische china wollten ja auch mal
nahmen brot dieses oder ballon brot
wollte es gerne machen oder viel von
albanisch also schreibt mir eure wünsche
ich hier in die kommentare da richte ich
mich sehr gerne nach und dann sehen wir
uns beim nächsten rezept und ich mag ihr
fleißig weiter ausgebaut und hilfe ist
auch noch motiviert ich habe mich leicht
erschrocken ok gute idee auf jeden fall
also bis dann tschüss
[Musik]